it is the second world series for the
rays it is the 21st for the dodgers
going back to their days in brooklyn the
donders with the best record in major
league baseball face the team with the
best record in the american league the
tampa bay rays
and tonight major league baseball honors
the frontline heroes who have inspired
us all year long
demonstrating resilience and
extraordinary commitment during the
pandemic joining us in center field for
the ceremonial first pitch for game one
of the world series are four amazing
examples of that spirit now
jamie will be throwing tonight's
ceremony of first pitch and doing the
catching her husband ryan
all right jamie let's see that pitch
[Applause]
thank you
here is the left-hander clayton kershaw
you look at the career numbers you look
at his resume former mvp three-time side
young award winner the post-season
record
under 500. two out
and then well margot coming up a ball of
striking two outs first and second top
of the first no score kershaw ground
ball slowly hit up the third base line
kershaw double pumps throws and just
gives margot by a step and that will end
the inning he is an all or nothing
proposition he'll hit some home runs
before he strikeout cedino strikes out
swinging third strikeout for kershaw
who's now retired six rays in a row diaz
is retired there's two hours plug on in
miss striker so kershaw has now struck
out of war nothing into the county the
02 swung on and missed strike three
six strikeouts for kershaw through four
he's retired 11 straight muncie is at
second base with one out and cody
bellinger coming up cody bellinger lifts
off high and deep to straight away
center field and gone
cody bellinger picking up where he left
off bellinger the big home run in the
seventh inning on sunday night it's a
two-run shot on this tuesday night and
the dodgers take a two to nothing lead i
can guarantee you he will not be doing
the
the bash brothers
in fact they're doing with defeat this
time
it's the low feet not the high five the
rays have not had a base runner since
the walk to randy rosarina
swung on and missed strike three on a
slider
seven strikeouts for kershaw tonight 200
career postseason strikeouts he has just
passed hall of famer john smoltz and
only justin verlander has collected more
two outs of the base is empty for kier
meyer who find the left field his first
time kk swings and drives one to right
field back out of dispatch to the wall
it's gone
kevin
with his first world series home run his
second home run of the post season
and he's cut the lead in half it's 2-1
and the rays out of nowhere have an
answer against kershaw who did give up
eight home runs during the regular
season and whether they can catch and
pass in this inning or not at least they
have some sort of an answer now the
infield is brought in for muncie second
and third one out as muncie grounds to
first now coming home
that beats the throw from diaz and the
dodgers take a three to one lead
the infield was in diaz had to go to his
right then turn and fire a seed to the
plate the fence was too quick dodgers
three to one first and third and one and
a shot in the left center field for
basic
and the score is seeger going first and
third is muncie and the dodgers
open up a 4-1 lead and they just keep on
turning the crank
a three-run lead a chance for more and
they have knocked out tyler glass now
now two out first and third and chris
taylor coming up swinging a line drive
basin into left field
in the score is muncie the third run of
the fifth
dodgers lead it five to one chris taylor
with the rbi single to left now with the
arbor of the left-handed pitcher on
tk hernandez is going to come up and
pinch it for jack peterson
here comes smith here's the throw not
hernandez he's made it six to one here
in the fifth
diaz has single right and bounced to
short here's a pick
turner from his knees what a play wow
from justin turner one out in the sixth
inning right here he gets a good break
on this ball and gloves it right into
webbing of his glove and then throws
from one knee across the diamond in time
the retiree andy diaz a terrific play at
third by
the veteran turner six to one top of the
order mookie beds first pitch with a fly
ball to right field heading on back and
brent throwing the wall and it's gone a
home run
mookie betts is doing nearly everything
a home run two stolen bases couple of
runs scored and on the first pitch of
the bottom of the six he hits a home run
to right one out muncie at the plate he
hits a rocket into right center field
that will not go short hops the wall
turner cruises to the plate it's an rbi
double for muncie and now the route is
on the dodgers eight and the rays won
eight one dodgers but with one out
margot at third base wendell at second
and here espresso to pinch hit and a
line driving to right a base hit one run
scores they will hold the runner wendell
at third in its first and third
a run in an 8-2 game and only one out in
the seventh and here's caremeyer homer
does last time having to face a
left-hander that's blooped into right
for another hit wendell scores brasso to
second it's eight to three dodgers and
the raise was suddenly an outstanding
approach at the plate and kevin kermier
left on left has two hits today and two
batted ends rosso at second kermit first
here comes mike cenino
line drive right back to the glove of
gonzales throws to second base and a
double play
meadows with margot on deck and wendell
to follow and a fly ball to center field
bellinger racing back and in front of
the wall he makes a leaping catch he may
have taken another home run away
it was ticketed for the raised bullpen
but bellinger would have none of it when
comebacker off the bare hand of kelly
deflects to seeger throws to first out
at first and the game is over
the dodgers win game one of the world
series